[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN ALBERT: Great, well,
thanks for coming out.
I want to preface this by saying
I do know Ben a little bit.
So if we exchange in
shorthand sometimes,
that's the explanation.
I've known him since
he was a child.
And Charlie, I'm a huge fan of.
And I wanted to sort of--
the idea, I think, for
doing this would be,
while I think a
lot of people think
that they know who
these two guys are,
I don't know that that's true.
And so I wanted to go
a little more in-depth
of who they are as a
people and as artists
and where this record
is coming from.
So I guess the first question,
which I find interesting,
is how you two met initially.
Because it has this sort of
almost mythical quality to me.
And so I'm wondering
if you guys could
sort of talk about
who introduced you
and how that happened.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Well, in 1993?
BEN HARPER: '93.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
John Lee Hooker
was playing at a little
club in Mill Valley,
California called
the Sweetwater,
and Ben was opening.
And John Lee had asked me to
come sit in with him-- which
we were real good
friends, so he often
asked me to come play
with him if I wasn't busy.
And that's where we all met.
BEN HARPER: Yeah.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: That
was the first meeting.
JOHN ALBERT: And it
was at his suggestion
that you guys initially
played together?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
At who's suggestion?
JOHN ALBERT: John Lee's.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
I don't know
whose idea it was that he open.
BEN HARPER: Well, I
got the opening gig--
I got the call from John Lee,
and we were at the same agency.
So it just was a clear fit.
And I remember
being in the room--
I knew I was going to
be opening for John Lee.
And while that was
clear, I had no idea
Charlie was going to be there.
So I walked into the
room and saw both of them
and jaw hit the floor.
And I just knew it was
going to be a special night.
And they welcomed me.
And I was absolutely just--
I was green.
I was peon on at that time.
And they were still
so good to me.
It was a special moment.
And that introduction
then grew into Charlie
and I are crossing paths at
different shows and festivals--
being on the same circuit.
And then, soon, we got
the call from John Lee
to record with him.
That was about '96, '97.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: He had an
album called "Just Friends?"
BEN HARPER: "Best of
Friends," I think.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
"Best of Friends."
And that's where we
really locked in.
BEN HARPER: That's
where it began.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
And even John Lee,
after we get through
recording, said,
man, you guys have got
to record more together.
BEN HARPER: Charlie,
you could hear him
on the end of the song.
At the end, you and I are
resonating our two notes,
and they kind of become
one haunted sound.
And John Lee is on the
record going, sounds
like a freight train
coming through here.
And they kept that
on the recording.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
The tune stops,
we still have our headphones on,
and John Lee goes, what's that?
BEN HARPER: That
sounds just like him.
And so how did that
experience eventually end up
with you guys formally
playing together and recording
together?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Well, since John
said that it was such
a good idea to do that
and we, obviously,
knew he was right--
BEN HARPER: Yeah.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: --and
we kept talking about it
for years, but we were so busy.
The problem was finding
a time when we would
both be off at the same time.
And boy, when we finally
got into the studio,
it's like all those tunes were
really restless and couldn't--
BEN HARPER: It's
like the music said
to us, what took you so long?
It felt like that to me, anyway.
And I hadn't felt
like that before.
It's like the music
said to us, like,
what took you two so long?
And it's about time.
And just one more
thing about John Lee.
He was a man of few words
I think it was fair to say.
And so when he looked
at me straight,
what with the dark glasses
on, kind of just went,
you know, hey, you and
Charlie have something here.
You should play
with Charlie Moore--
you and Charlie.
And that always stuck with me.
Because he never really gave
me any more in life instruction
than that, so that
was a big deal.
JOHN ALBERT: With
you Charlie, I just
want to know if you can
sort of tell these people--
your formative years
were in Memphis,
and then you move to Chicago.
And I'm wondering if you
can explain to these people
why you moved to Chicago
in the first place,
and then if we can talk a little
bit about what you found there?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: Well, the
only reason I went to Chicago
was just looking for
a job in a factory,
because that's all I
knew about Chicago.
It was like this
great, big town way
up north with lots
of factory work
that paid well and
had lots of benefits.
And friends of mine had
gone up and gotten a job
and had come back
to visit in a brand
new, big, red
Oldsmobile or something.
And I kept thinking
about, yeah, I've
got to get up and get
me one of them jobs.
But I never thought about--
there was a blues scene there.
Because I'd been told that
all entertainers either
lived in New York or Hollywood.
So to me, this is just a
big factory town up north.
But when I got there,
boy, did my eyes opened.
JOHN ALBERT: And so you
started going to clubs, right?
And catching all these
artists that you knew about?
And I'm wondering, at that
time, were those clubs
fairly segregated?
And was it odd for
you to be there?
Or was it normal?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Well, I had already
learned how to play
in Memphis and drink.
So it's a common
pastime in Memphis.
But when I got up to Chicago,
I wasn't promoting myself
or wanting to sit in or--
I just was hanging out,
and I would request tunes.
And all these guys
thought of me as a fan.
Rarely would you see
any white people.
Sometimes a bunch of kids
from the University of Chicago
would park as close as they
could to the front door and all
run in together in a group--
tight little group,
with their eyes real big
looking all around real scared.
And I'm sitting at the
bar and thinking, oh no.
Don't come talk to me.
So that was the
beginning of hanging out
in the blues clubs in Chicago.
JOHN ALBERT: And how did
you go from hanging out
to actually playing?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Well, a waitress
that I got to know pretty well--
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
--told Muddy, oh, you
ought to hear Charlie
play harmonica.
And Muddy was like,
Charlie plays harmonica?
Well, next thing I know,
he's calling me up to sit in.
And that changed everything.
Because a lot of musicians
hung out at Pepper's Lounge,
which was Muddy's home club
when he wasn't on the road,
because he lived right
around the corner.
And people started
offering me gigs.
They'd say, hey,
come on by Wednesday
night at it's this place, man.
We can pay you a few bucks.
And, pay me a few bucks?
What?
So that got my
attention because that
was my ticket out of the
factory and my ticket to fun.
JOHN ALBERT: One of
the things that I
think you guys have in
common at different places
and at different times
was that you were
both sort of musical seekers--
like looking for records,
finding new music.
And Ben, you grew up sort of
amongst musicians-- you know,
your family was musicians.
You had the Folk Music Center.
But were there records that you
went outside of your comfort
zone to find?
I mean, whether it
was like looking--
whether it was hip hop or
what other genres that you
went out and looked for?
BEN HARPER: Yeah, after
mistreating my mom's record
collection severely, she
bought me a Radio Shack
realistic turntable--
I think it had
built-in speakers--
and gave me a little
lunch money and said,
OK, you've got to go pick
out your own records.
You've got your
own record player.
Because this is
getting ridiculous.
My records are all
coming up scratched.
And the first record I
bought was "Smash Hits"
with the cover of Hendrix
on the front with the three
different hand positions.
And I don't know what
pulled me to buy it.
I don't know.
What was a nine-year-old
doing buying a Hendrix record?
But that's what I did.
And that introduced
me to a whole world
of music, rock and alternative
at that time period.
It was that exploration.
And that was the
cross-pollination
of my love for blues
and rock and roll.
And then in my teenage years,
it was the first wave--
well, maybe the second wave of
hip hop which was my music--
that was my voice and my
music from my teenage years
that represented my
rebellion and my voice.
I caught the tail end
of the Sugarhill Gang,
which then segued into
all things hip hop--
you know, EPMD, and Run-DMC, and
Whodini, and the Beastie Boys.
JOHN ALBERT: And
Charlie, we talked once
when you were talking about
looking through records--
like going to like old antique
stores and finding records.
And I'm wondering,
besides the blues,
if there were other
types of music
that you sort of felt
a relationship with?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: Well, I
was just and in these old junk
stores.
The 78s were like
a nickel or a dime.
And I'm just looking for blues.
But if I saw anything
that looked interesting,
I'd just get that,
too, to take home,
listen to it just to see
what it sounded like.
So I discovered a lot of
music from around the world
that the scales they were
using reminded me of blues.
And after a while,
I got to realizing
that maybe every
culture around the world
has this music of lament about--
they're all singing
about, my baby left me.
It's a worldwide situation.
So everybody's got
the blues, really.
They might not call it
that in another country,
but that's what we call it.
It's the same theme, though.
JOHN ALBERT: Yeah, I'm
wondering how these--
because you both
have like both played
in different genres of
music and experimented
with different influences.
And in a record like this,
which is a blues record,
does that still
come into the sound?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: I
guess all my influences,
either consciously
or subconsciously,
surface from time to time.
That's what happens with me.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
It's hard to say.
JOHN ALBERT: What about you Ben?
BEN HARPER: Yeah, I
think that's a huge piece
as far as the influence
and other influences
that you filter
through your voice
and how it ends up being a part
of your main genre of interest
or genre of commitment.
In my family's music
store growing up as a kid,
this was before anybody--
there was no world music.
There was just music from
around the world in the '70s.
And then, as you know--
you know as well as I
do, that music store
is an explosion of influence
from music all around the world
and has been--
it's our 60th
anniversary this year.
We've had the doors opened
and family run for 60 years--
five generations working
the cash register--
me specifically at
the holiday time.
I think people come
into the music store
and give me a little bit
more abuse because like, oh,
you left town, didn't you?
So now, you're going
to change the A
string on my kid's violin.
So there's a certain
mandatory humility
when I'm back
working in the music
store around the
holidays, and it's great.
I love it.
But a little bit off
topic, just to say that--
and literature and
literary references.
I don't quote poetry and
poets and things like that.
But on the shelves
at my house was,
the "Joy of Yiddish" cookbook--
"The Crucible--" the play "The
Crucible," "Arthur Miller,"
and Alex Haley's "Roots"
would be in a row.
And so that that's
how I grew up.
JOHN ALBERT: And
so this is like--
it's a blues record,
but I'm wondering
if within playing
and doing a record
that's sort of a
genre record, is there
some sort of liberating
feel to doing
that, in terms of creatively?
Like, you don't have to worry
about reinventing something--
so that it becomes more
of an emotional exercise?
BEN HARPER: For
me, the blues was
the music that motivated me,
and inspired me, and hit me
like a thunderbolt, and
brought me to my instrument,
and set my life's course.
As much as I've been
in throughout so
many other genres, getting
to work with Charlie,
it's coming home.
It's where I started.
It's the first music
where I was recognized
for doing something that
had the chance of possibly
being unique.
And the blues has a way
of taking care of its own
in that Muddy had Charlie up
on stage in a very special way.
That's a stretch for Mud'
to say, hey, you're with me.
Come on up.
At a young age, I can only
imagine what that would have
been like for Muddy Waters
to invite you onstage,
irregardless of color,
or culture, or age,
either you can
play or you can't.
And that's what Taj Mahal
did for me when I was a kid.
Taj invited me out on tour
when I was a 22-year-old steel
guitar player.
And he said, hey,
man, you're with me.
And it's the genre
that discovered me,
and that I discovered,
and it changed my life.
So to work with
Charlie again, it's
the arrival in full circle--
place to land.
JOHN ALBERT: I'm wondering-- you
guys have been playing together
for a while.
And I'm wondering if your
relationship has changed
and that has affected the music?
I mean, because you guys have
been friends for a while,
and you spend a lot
of time together.
And I'm wondering how that is
reflected in this new record,
specifically.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Well, any time
you spend a couple of years
on the road with somebody,
you're gonna know them
a whole lot better
at the end of those two years.
BEN HARPER: That's the truth.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
And a lot of it
along the way was just
confirming our suspicions.
BEN HARPER: That's right.
And make no mistake,
nobody ever will know me.
I'm impossible to know.
The only people that
really know me--
two ex-wives, my wife,
my five kids, my mother,
and my two brothers are the only
people that will ever know me.
And I wish it weren't so, and
I wish I weren't so guarded.
It's just who I am.
But outside of that, the
only person that knows me
is Charlie.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: And Ben
knows me like few people,
except Henrietta.
JOHN ALBERT: And Charlie,
in playing with Ben,
has your actual playing evolved
in your musical relationship
with him?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
I like to think
I've been evolving since the
day I started playing as a kid.
And any time I play with--
if I'm playing with
my own band, I'm
not going to be learning so much
because they're just backing me
up, and I'm just
playing what I know.
But when I'm with Ben,
I'm listening to him,
and I'm sparking off his ideas.
And it's giving me new ideas.
And it's a growth
period, really.
BEN HARPER: Same.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: So it's
really exciting on many levels,
but that's one of them.
JOHN ALBERT: And Ben, in terms
of writing lyrics and writing
these songs, how is it
different than when you're
writing a record for yourself,
when you're anticipating
that this is
something you're going
to play with the two of you?
BEN HARPER: When I'm
writing for myself,
I have as high a
standard as possible.
But you can only elevate
yourself by yourself
so far and so high.
And hopefully, that's high.
Hopefully that's good enough to
get you to a seat at the table.
But when I'm aiming towards
working and writing around
Charlie and the
sound of his harp,
it's like All-Star Weekend--
NBA All-Star.
It's got to be something else.
And again, just
like Charlie said,
he pushes me to grow
as a lyricist in a way
that I couldn't otherwise.
JOHN ALBERT: I mean, both of you
guys are incredible musicians,
and I think you could
just rely on that.
But what I see in this
record is something
that's really intensely
emotional and personal.
And so you've sort of
transcended the playing
to create something
that has a narrative
and talks about your lives.
And I think it's interesting.
Because neither of you nor
me are particularly young,
so you've lived life.
And it feels like, to
me, that it comes through
in this record.
And I'm wondering if you can
talk about whether this is
autobiographical or if it's--
what it is to you guys--
what it represents?
BEN HARPER: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: You.
BEN HARPER: Yeah, we have that--
neither one of us want to
step on each other, so it's--
yeah.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
For me, it's
really exciting because
blues is important to me.
It's almost like a philosophy
or way of looking at life.
It's actually more than
just another kind of music.
It's not a fad.
And to see it accessible
today and not a rehash of like
a Muddy Waters tune from 1953,
which a lot of people do--
and that's OK--
but it's great, and refreshing,
and means a lot to me
to see it still get
the core feeling that
makes it real blues, but
it's brand new of today
and of the 21st century.
And it just means that the blues
is alive and well and tough
as hell.
And you can't kill it.
And it's gonna keep on going.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN ALBERT: Well, I
mean, talk a little bit
about some of the
lyrics and the songs.
I mean, because there's a
certain sense of reflection
in these songs.
BEN HARPER: Yeah, for sure.
There's sight, sound,
taste, touch, scent.
Art reminds us that, as human
beings, there is a sixth sense,
and that's intuition.
And art's supposed to bring
out the best in our intuitions
as human beings, as
far as I'm concerned.
And the blues-- you
can't fool the blues.
And either it's
blue or it's not.
And this record, lyrically--
this record exhausted me, Jay.
I've never been lyrically
exhausted in my life.
My second record's done
by the time I get--
my next record is
usually done by the time
I'm finished with the
record I'm working on--
just because it's been
my natural course.
And I never lift
pen up from paper.
I never do.
Every conversation I ever have,
every book I ever read, every--
it's all working its way
into becoming a song.
My life is a song filter--
lyrical filter.
But this is the first record
that lyrically exhausted me.
I've got nothing
after this one--
at the moment.
[LAUGHTER]
I think we're both probably
sidestepping your question--
how personal is it.
And if a record's not
personal when you write it,
it is once you've recorded it.
Everything you say is--
and the danger and the
power in the unconscious--
are you trying to tell
yourself something?
Are you reading into the future
about how you want to live
or where you may be going?
Blues, when at its best,
is about the past, present,
and the future.
There's not a word
or a syllable in this
record that hasn't either been
lived or been lived by someone
incredibly close to me.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: That
gives you where to go.
BEN HARPER: OK.
JOHN ALBERT: Yeah,
I mean it's just--
there's an intensity,
an emotional intensity
in this record, beyond the
playing, which is noticeable.
One of the things I want to
ask you about your playing
is that--
to go back when I was
talking about influences,
one of the things that
I hear in your playing
is there's a phrasing
that, while it's blues,
like you can hear like
a jazz quality to it.
And I'm wondering, is
that just something
that comes out of who you are?
Or is that deliberate?
Or--?
I mean, especially,
on this record,
there's phrasing that's
really fascinating to me.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Well, that's interesting.
I have no idea what I
sound like to anybody else.
So I wish I could put your
head on and listen to myself.
JOHN ALBERT: I'm sure somebody
here could arrange that.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN HARPER: We are at Google.
JOHN ALBERT: Yeah, we are.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: But I
listen to all kinds of music--
gospel-- and growing
up in Memphis.
I heard a lot of rockabilly,
and gospel, and blues,
and it all meant
something to me.
And I listen to a lot
of jazz, especially
after I got to Chicago.
There was a lot of jazz all
over Chicago on the jukeboxes
and the blues clubs--
you know, Jack McDuff
and guys liked that.
And they say it's jazz, but
man, everything they're playing
is blues, except for
the ballads they did.
Like, Grant Green is
a jazz guitar player,
but many of his riffs--
they just fit right on
the harmonica perfectly.
So I got a lot of ideas
listening to jazz players.
And a lot of those guys would
come in and sit in with us,
we'd go sit in with them.
There was a lot of
crossover in Chicago.
JOHN ALBERT: And both of
you have had these sort
of fascinating careers.
Because you're not
born out of one
particular musical movement.
I mean, I'm aware
of like-- you know,
you show up in San
Francisco in the '60s,
and you're playing the
Fillmore, but you're
not a hippie by any means,
but they're responding to you.
And in the same way,
Ben, you've played
like different types of
music, but you're not
identified with one thing.
And people-- sometimes I
think they don't really know--
BEN HARPER: Oh, no, make
no mistake about it, man,
I am the only living human being
that's opened up for Metallica,
and Marilyn Manson,
and John Lee Hooker.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN ALBERT: That's
an accomplishment.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN ALBERT: So
there are benefits.
And I'm wondering if that sort
of quality that you both have,
which is that you sort of
transcended particular genres--
is it a positive?
Or do you see it as a negative
in how it affects what you do?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: I
think it's a huge positive.
If it's a way to pull people in,
and expose them to something,
and treat them to something
new they hadn't heard before,
it'll be with them for
the rest of their life.
That's the nature of blues.
It'll get you through life.
It's your buddy when you're
up, and it's your comforter
when you're down.
BEN HARPER: Before I touch
on that in particular,
do you mind if I just dip back
to the lyrics for a second?
JOHN ALBERT: Yeah, please.
BEN HARPER: I mean, it's hard
to have a lyric that says,
"There's a price we
pay for the places
we lay for putting
it all on the line--
so far down the only sound is
something leaving you behind--"
like, you can't
write that and not
have-- you mean what I mean?
And so it is some personal shit.
You don't have to suffer to
play the blues, but it fuckin'
helps.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: Yeah, yeah.
BEN HARPER: So yeah,
damn right it's personal.
This shit is as personal
as I've ever been.
It's raw.
I may as well burn my
diary, really, in a way.
I mean, it is kind
of that gnarly.
I might as well just walk
on stage every night,
burn up my life on
pages, and walk off.
But if the blues isn't that,
don't waste anybody's time.
JOHN ALBERT: Well, how does
that feel to put that out there
like that?
BEN HARPER: It's actually--
just rehearsing-- we've
been rehearsing for
the last three days.
And man, even--
I'm a shell, dude.
I'm a shell, even just from
rehearsing these songs.
So I've got to pace
myself for sure.
I've got to like eat my
dark leafy greens and my--
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN ALBERT: And are
there any particular songs
that feel like--
that are incredibly
cathartic on this album?
BEN HARPER: Yeah, "The Bottle
Wins Again--" you know,
and having to bring
that to the surface
as far as wrestling
that into submission.
You know, I'm a year
sober, which feels great.
I bought myself a big,
big cake to celebrate.
And all of them, man.
All of them kind of-- they
weigh heavy in their own.
"These days I speak in
whispers, travel lonely to
and from, come close
you'll see the red
of a well-bitten tongue."
My family had to
survive McCarthyism
and was chased from coast to
coast for not dropping names.
My grandfather
wouldn't drop names,
so he got fired and chased
after by the powers that
be and couldn't
stay in the town he
lived, because he couldn't work
when you're blacklisted, right?
So that's how I ended up
in Southern California,
because my grandfather dug
ditches from East Coast
to West because he couldn't
get a job because he wouldn't
name names.
So I don't know how I
got onto that, but--
JOHN ALBERT: It's good.
I mean, yeah, I mean,
the sense that I get it--
BEN HARPER: Oh, no, to
finish the thought--
"These days I speak in whispers,
travel lonely to and from,
come close you'll see the
red of a well-bitten tongue--
the righteous, the wretched,
the holy and the damned,
is there no mercy in this land?"
And it is as merciless a time
in sociopolitical history
as we've been in--
at least in my lifetime.
So yeah, all of it weighs
heavy in its own way,
as far as being either about
or around what [INAUDIBLE]
going through you hope.
JOHN ALBERT: Well, do
you think that, I mean--
is it an optimistic record?
Is there hope in there?
BEN HARPER: I think even
asking the question,
"Is there no mercy
in this land?"
is optimistic because it
reminds us that that should be--
home of the brave,
land of the free--
there should be
a third line that
has something to do with
mercy, as far as I'm concerned.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: The
blues is always optimistic.
Even though you might be
talking about times are tough,
the nature of blues is,
we'll get through this.
We can do it.
We're tough.
JOHN ALBERT: So we should
open it up to questions now.
And we can't really
see out there,
but is there anybody that
has particular questions
for these guys?
My grandpa is a big
Johnny Cash fan.
So I understand that you
maybe spent some time together
in Memphis.
Can you maybe just talk
about the influence
that listening to
Johnny Cash had on you
and how his style maybe plays
into the work that you've done?
BEN HARPER: Great question.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
What was the question?
JOHN ALBERT: Johnny Cash.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
What about Johnny Cash?
AUDIENCE: Does your
experience listening to him,
growing up around him--
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: Oh, I
used to see him around Memphis.
His brother Tommy, we went
to high school together.
Tommy was on the
basketball team.
BEN HARPER: There's a Johnny
and a Tommy Cash in this--
[LAUGHTER]
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
And actually, there
was an older brother named
Roy that had a radio show
every Saturday for 15 minutes--
a little hillbilly show.
Anyhow, Johnny would come to
the high school basketball games
to see Tommy along with Dewey
Philips, a local madman DJ.
So yeah, I saw a lot of
Johnny at the basketball games
along with a lot of other local
rockabilly guys and stuff--
Charlie Feathers and
people liked that.
JOHN ALBERT: To paraphrase,
was his music ever
an influence on you?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Johnny Cash's music?
Oh, I had every thing
he issued on the Sun.
And then when he
moved on to Columbia,
I had everything for a
while, then it kind of--
But yeah, I was a huge fan.
I even recorded a
version of "Big River"
for what it's worth.
AUDIENCE: Both of
you, as musicians,
have inspired so many people.
I mean, even just
before we started,
people were saying how this
song got me through that,
or like this inspired
me to do that.
As artists, what inspires you
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: Who?
Me?
AUDIENCE: Both of you.
Because your music has been so
inspirational to other people,
what inspires you?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: You
mean like a particular tune,
or artist, or anything in life?
AUDIENCE: Anything--
rainbows, music, TV, whatever.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Fear inspires me.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: That is
a wonderful answer.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Blues always--
when I was a little kid,
I was the only child
of a single mom who would
get up in the morning
when it was dark, and
ride three buses to work,
and then three buses
home, and it would be dark
when she got back.
So I was alone all the time.
And when I would hear blues--
blues is just in
the environment.
It was my comforter.
It made me feel better.
And that's the beginning for me.
The blues helped me
feel OK about myself.
BEN HARPER: And before
I answer your question,
if I could just double
back again because--
AUDIENCE: Sure, sure.
BEN HARPER: --it is
so conversational
having known John all my life.
But how it's affected me being
as eclectic of a career--
how that's come into play?
I wouldn't have
it any other way.
It's brought me to
where I am today.
It hasn't been
easy because it's--
you sidestep-- there's
a certain comfort
in knowing how an
artist is going to sound
or how a band is going
to sound from first song
to last, from one
record to another.
And that's never been for me.
So it's made it
super challenging.
But at the end of the day, as
we were discussing on the way
here, you're just so
fortunate to have people
at all from one
record to another,
whether you're eclectic or not.
So I've always let the
music lead the charge
and celebrated the eclectic
nature of my musical interests.
JOHN ALBERT: You know, one
of the things I'd add--
BEN HARPER: Sorry,
[INAUDIBLE],, I'll be right--
JOHN ALBERT: --yeah-- is that,
in collaborating with people--
and especially with Charlie--
it seems to have kept
like an immediacy
and keeping you
inspired in some way.
So you're not just sort of
doing the same record over
and different ways.
BEN HARPER: It served
me in that way for sure.
And usually, one record
inspires the next in my life,
but this is the first record
I feel every record I've ever
made has gone into this one.
JOHN ALBERT: You know, I
would just say, from my point
of view, I've never seen Ben
as excited about a record
as this one.
And you've made a few records.
BEN HARPER: Yeah.
JOHN ALBERT: And so I think to
be experiencing that right now
is--
I mean, it's a
testament to the record
and a testament to
the collaboration.
And it's pretty amazing.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
If you had known me
as long as you've
known Ben, you'd say,
I've ever seen Charlie
so excited, either.
JOHN ALBERT: I'm
aware of that, yes.
BEN HARPER: And I would say, for
me, what inspires me to do it
and to continue to do it is the
communication-- the prospect
of communicating globally as
well as just individually.
To be able to communicate
with you with my pen,
it makes me getting--
so I'm so intimidated
by a blank page and a full pen.
Like, darn it!
The pen's not out of ink.
No excuses.
And to be able to get-- have
this opportunity in a lifetime
to communicate globally
in the way music offers
the opportunity to do, is--
it's the best part of it.
And the pain of your life
that goes into your music--
I'd say our pain
is your teacher.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Does that make sense?
BEN HARPER: That's fair to say.
But however, there's
a paradox wrapped
in a conundrum wrapped in a--
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: An enigma.
BEN HARPER: --in
irony, which is,
I was walking through
the streets of Portugal
with some friends.
This is when I was
having a moment.
I was recognized in the
streets by 40, 50 people,
and they were all--
and kids like
pulling on my jacket.
And they were singing,
"With My Own Two Hands."
I have a song--
I should never presume
anyone knows what I'm doing.
There's a song called "With My
Own Two Hands" that I wrote,
and it's super optimistic.
And there's no song
I'm more proud of.
And they started singing the
whole song, "With My Own Two
Hands," and I'm going, wow.
I've really made
a positive impact.
And then it segued.
They went from that song into
a song called "Burn One Down"
that I've written
about smoking weed.
And then, I went, oh--
and that one was even louder.
And I went, what have I done?
So sometimes that
communication is
in conflict-- direct
conflict with itself,
but it's the communication
component for me.
AUDIENCE: Wonderful.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you guys
mentioned Muddy and Taj
Mahal as big influences and guys
who kind of brought you along.
Curious if you've got any good
stories about younger guys
you might be particularly
proud of having
brought along yourselves?
BEN HARPER: I'd have
to say Jack Johnson.
Because I went from seeing him
in the front row of a show,
to getting his demo
tape, to playing
on one of his first
songs called "Flake,"
and he must have opened--
the first shows he ever
played on the world stage
were opening for myself
and the Innocent Criminals.
And to see him just
launch into the ether
from that has been a
permanent source of--
I just feel a certain sense--
whenever I see him doing
anything great-- and
everything he does is great--
I always take a certain sense
of pride in seeing that.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit more about the title track?
When I heard it, it just
grabbed me at the heart.
And I wanted to get your
insights a little bit more
about some of the lyrics, and
the power, and the meaning,
and the message behind it.
BEN HARPER: Well,
the song, initially--
the first verse for the
song was written in honor,
in memoriam of Charlie's mom.
I know Charlie and I--
I don't want to speak
to something that--
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: It's OK.
BEN HARPER: But something that
happened in Charlie's life
affected me to the point
where I had to write it.
And then, the song
spread from that verse
into what is the song,
"No Mercy in this Land."
And I brought the
song to Charlie
to check in with him
because it was so heavy,
and it affected me so deeply,
I had to put it on paper.
But it was Charlie's life
that I was writing, so it's--
you can see where
that's fragile.
And Charlie said it was OK.
I mean, he let it live.
He let me do it.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: Thank you.
JOHN ALBERT:
Charlie can you talk
about how-- because
I understand-- like,
you can see that it's a
delicate, sensitive thing,
but what was it like
hearing the lyrics that he
wrote about that?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
Well, I didn't
want to keep the
death of my mother
and the way she was
murdered buried in me.
Because then, it
would just fester,
I was afraid and have an
effect on me mentally.
So I liked to be able to just
talk about it if the time was
appropriate.
And to have it in a
song really makes it--
I don't know the word to say--
special-- there's another
word I want to say,
but it lets it breathe,
and it puts the sun on it,
and let's it not kill me,
so I can deal with it--
in a nutshell.
JOHN ALBERT: And was
it always the plan
to have him sing those lines?
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE:
No, that was his idea.
BEN HARPER: Well, I just--
it was a bit of a subversive
tactic in that I had the song
and I just, I said, hey,
Charlie, I've got this song,
and is there
anything in this song
that you'd want to sing maybe?
You know, I just kind
of brought it to him.
I didn't make anything of it.
I just presented him the song
when it was done and said,
I'd love to duet this with
you if you're comfortable.
And Charlie just picked his
lines and was, let's get to it.
CHARLIE MUSSELWHITE: Thank you.
BEN HARPER: Thank
you for letting me--
letting me write it.
JOHN ALBERT: Thank
you all for coming.
Thank you guys for doing this.
BEN HARPER: Thank you-- so much.
[APPLAUSE]